antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir peut-être un
tournant dans la guerre du golfe les
revers subis par l'iran depuis 48 heures
face aux américains et à l'irak suscite
bon nombre d'interrogations
le régime de téhéran de l'ayatollah
khomeini va-t-il accepter une issue
honorable ou au contraire affiché sa
détermination nous essaierons de
répondre dans quelques instants
en compagnie de pierre serra
pierre desproges en flagrant délire de
mort bouffon insolent loufoque
flegmatique jusqu'au bout terrassé par
un cancer
une otage du boeing cousine de l'émir du
koweit subit à son tour les autorités
koweïtiennes de céder aux exigences des
pirates négociations au ralenti sur
l'aéroport d'alger vinacapital dans
l'état de new york un scrutin décisif
dans la courbe du kaki jackson en vue de
l'investiture démocrate pour la
présidentielle américaine
arrivée de la dépouille d'abou jihad à
damas interrogations sur la présence
d'arafat demain aux funérailles
on y voyait l'occasion d'une
réconciliation avec le régime syrien
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann
marcel carton les otages français au
liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés
sans doute un nouvel espoir pour les
malades du coeur je vous rappelle que
300 personnes attendent en ce moment
même une transplantation cardiaque et
que plusieurs milliers d'entre nous sont
à la merci d'un infarctus du myocarde
il ya quelques minutes au cours d'un
congrès international de cardiologie à
los angeles en californie
un professeur français le professeur
carpentier a révélé qu'il venait de
mettre au point une nouvelle technique
baptisée cardio mis au plastique le
principe de cette technique est simple
il s'agit de remplacer la partie
défaillante du coeur par un autre muscle
le professeur carpentier a précisé que
plusieurs malades vivent parfaitement
grâce à cette nouvelle technique
explications de daniel duigou sylviane à
41 ans elle est la première malade avoir
bénéficié de la nouvelle chirurgie
absolument révolutionnaire qu'est la
cardiomyopathie hier cette femme était
condamné aujourd'hui elle vit parce
qu'on lui a remplacé une partie du
choeur par un autre muscle étonnante
technique opératoire qui ressemble à de
l'artisanat et qui pourtant a des
conséquences scientifique considérable
jugez en vous même d'abord vu de dos on
prend un grand muscle grand dorsal que
l' on sectionne à la base
ensuite vu deux devant on coupe une côte
pour faire passer le muscle du dos à
l'intérieur de la cage thoracique et
pour entourer le coeur comme une écharpe
il ne reste plus qu'à stimuler le muscle
avec un pacemaker pour qu'il remplace le
coeur défaillant grèce et j'avais une
tumeur au coeur sans qu'on vous a
carrément enlever une partie du coeur
vous avez bénéficié de la cardio
plastique est ce que vous considérez
comme sauvée mais il y a plus étonnant
la structure du muscle qui remplace le
coeur se met au bout d'un certain temps
ressemblait à la structure même du coeur
quand on a stimulé le muscle électrique
main pendant six semaines
on s'aperçoit que
les fibres qui constitue le musée et
même les protéines qui constituent le
must c'est à dire la myosine se sont
transformés et ont pris des caractères
qui ressemble au muscle cardiaque et à
la myosine car bien des gens en france
six manades vivent parfaitement après
une cardiomyopathie peut-on parler de
tournant dans la guerre du golfe nous
essaierons de répondre dans quelques
instants mais une chose est certaine
l'iran vient de subir coup sur coup deux
revers cuisant dans le golfe persique et
sur le front irakien en mer la marine
iranienne est sorti plutôt mal en point
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire des
affrontements qui ont opposé ces
dernières 48 heures l us navy
certes le régime de l'ayatollah khomeini
prétend avoir détruit un hélicoptère
américain
mais au même moment trois bâtiments de
guerre et plusieurs vedettes rapides
iraniennes ont été mises hors de combat
problème également sur terre où les
troupes de terrain ont dû évacuer une
bonne partie de la presqu'île de fao qui
avait été gagnée de haute lutte en 1986
le point tout de suite avec jérôme boni
patrouille américaine trafic commercial
interrompue la tension reste vive
aujourd'hui dans le golfe arabo persique
au sud les pompiers et c'est encore en
ce moment même de maîtriser les
incendies provoqués par les opérations
navales dernière victime des vedettes
rapides iranienne ce transporteur de
charbon le fal cinq appartenant aux
émirats arabes unis
la flottille des gardiens de la
révolution reprend aujourd'hui des
objectifs civils après les tentatives
d'affrontement direct avec la marine
américaine
hier qui ont coûté très cher à terre
trois de ces quelques 18 navires anéanti
on vient d'apprendre que cinq missiles
silkworm avaient été tirées de l'iran
vers des navires américains qui auraient
réussi à brouiller leurs systèmes de
guidage les missiles sont tombés dans
l'eau malgré la disparition d'un
hélicoptère d'assaut américain de type
cobra
ce sont bien les iraniens qui ont perdu
la bataille du golfe et dans le même
temps bagdad annoncé images triomphante
à l'appui que les troupes irakiennes
avaient repris la péninsule stratégique
de fao occupé partiellement depuis deux
ans par les iraniens selon la télévision
irakienne
ces images du président saddam hussein
félicitant ses troupes ont été tournées
à fayoum m c'est donc une guerre
défensive sur deux fronts l'irak et le
sud du golfe que doit mener aujourd'hui
l'iran qui mobilise tout en accusant le
grand satan américain de complot avec
l'ennemi irakien oui alors question
carcérale faut-il croire les iraniens
quand il parle de collusion entre les
américains et les irakiens écoutez
d'abord choquée vous pensez que
washington affirme qu'il n'y a pas de
collusion et qui se contentent d
americas contente d'assurer le rôle dans
le golfe c'est à dire de préserver la
navigation commerciale dans une voie
d'eau internationale c'est donc pas d'
escalade du côté américain
évidemment les iraniens d'intérêt au
contraire mais il faut comprendre que
ans quand on considère l'irak
s'il n'y a pas qu'au l'égide des
américains il ya au moins en tout cas
parce que rossi s'est passé dans le
golfe
et ce qui se passe à fao une relation
direct de cause à effet il ya deux ans
que les iraniens et irakiens tentaient
de reprendre face aux autres choisis ces
jours ci pour le faire c'est par hasard
alors qu'hier faut-il prendre au sérieux
les témoignages qui prétendent que
l'armée iranienne est traumatisé depuis
quelques temps démoralisé
oui enfin on le dit mais la guerre que
depuis huit ans il ya plus d'un million
de morts
rom sur les deux parties c'est quand
même très grave mais je crois qu'il faut
quand même se rappeler une chose c'est
quand la guerre a commencé on disait
belles armes iraniennes intel et après
la chute du chah que ça n'a pas duré une
semaine ça fait huit ans et que l'irak
l'iran plutôt à une réserve d'hommes
extraordinaire en même temps surtout il
y a chez les chiites quand ils sont
enfin d'attiser une espèce de
fascination du martyr qui fait que la
réserve semble inépuisable il que
peuvent faire les rangs on a
l'impression que son attitude était
suicidaire les jours derniers ce suicide
et on ne sait pas je vous répète que les
airs d'homme par et inépuisable je pense
que l'iran peut continuer longtemps
et puis vient bien sûr les reports
d'alger 15e jour de détournement pour le
boeing déco et r'way sur place c'était
l'impasse tout au moins jusqu'à cet
après midi on avait l'impression que les
médiateurs comme les pirates de l'air
d'ailleurs était plus ou moins dépassé
par la tournure des événements depuis
tout à l'heure les pirates ont repris
l'initiative des opérations en annonçant
qu'il souhaitait faire une deuxième
déclaration à la presse
on murmure également un léger qu'une
importante personnalité serait monté par
le conditionnel à bord de l'appareil
confirmation alger avec notre envoyé
spécial hervé brusini parole contre
parole
d'abord ce sont les pirates qui veulent
lancer un message à la presse via la
radio du boeing on verra même l'un d'eux
cachée sous sa cagoule sortir la tête
d'une trappe de l'avion là juste au
dessus du cockpit attendait le redis la
tour de contrôle un émissaire importante
doit venir vous voir
commence alors un étrange ballet de la
passerelle d'embarquement en avant en
arrière
et pendant ce temps un conciliabule se
tient à l'écart entre l'ancien premier
ministre
abd el ghali semble-t-il et un autre
homme et c'est lui qui finalement
montent dans l'avion
durée de l'entretien une vingtaine de
minutes une heure plus tard ce n'est pas
un communiqué mais c'est encore un otage
que les pirates font entendre
cette fois c'est une femme un membre
direct de la famille royale
anwar al sabah je demande à ma famille à
mon gouvernement de précipiter dit elle
la libération des 17 détenus du koweit
ses derniers mots seront nous sommes
évidemment en danger en fait la clé de
toute cette affaire se trouvent très
probablement au liban selon plusieurs
sources le véritable événement
d'aujourd'hui ne serait autre qu'une
réponse
une réponse venant de beyrouth de la
part des complices des pirates de l'air
très certainement le hezbollah
pro-iranien une réponse faite à
d'éventuelles propositions que vous êtes
yens sur le devenir des 17 détenus en
quelque sorte l'aéroport d'alger ne
serait que la vitrine de la menace le
centre de décision lui se trouvant à
beyrouth
les obsèques d'abou jihad le dirigeant
palestinien assassiné samedi à tunis se
dérouleront demain à damas le commandant
en chef adjoint des forces
palestiniennes sera enterré au cimetière
des martyrs du camp de yarmouk dans la
banlieue sud de damas la dépouille
mortelle d'abou jihad est arrivé cet
après midi dans la capitale syrienne
l'épousé du dirigeant palestinien et
quatre de ses enfants se trouvaient à
bord de l'appareil
ils ont été accueillis par de nombreuses
personnalités dont georges habache
le secrétaire général du front populaire
de libération de la palestine yasser
arafat le leader de l'olp est finalement
resté à tunis les observateurs estiment
qu'il s'est plié à la fois à des
conditions de sécurité et à des
conditions politiques arafat a dit adieu
à son ami c'était ce matin sur
l'aéroport de tunis car depuis 1984 le
chemin de damas lui est interdit martine
laroche joubert ce matin à tunis
l'émotion mais aussi la vengeance avec
notre âme et avec notre sang nous te
vengerons après la révolution
nous vaincrons scandé les quelques
centaines de palestiniens réunis ici
il attendait aussi yasser arafat
bouleversé par la mort d'un de ses plus
proches amis au début de la cérémonie
il semblait vaincu par l'émotion avant
de prendre à nouveau la tête du combat
l'israélien s'imaginent qu'ils vont
éteindre le feu de la révolution dans
les territoires occupés eh bien il se
trompe
les principaux dirigeants palestiniens
étaient ici ce matin
yasser arafat n'ira pas à l'enterrement
à damas mais cette cérémonie a déjà une
valeur symbole
retour en france à cinq jours exactement
du premier tour les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle tiennent leur
tout dernier meeting
nous allons tout de suite faire le point
avec nos confrères du service politique
raymond barre sur le terrain dans sa
bonne ville de lyon le candidat bar
tiendra un meeting ce soir
avant cela il y as dalo guila dialoguer
longuement avec les élus locaux pour
leur répéter inlassablement la même
chose qu'il avait l'intention de se
battre jusqu'au bout
contrairement à ce que beaucoup pensent
at il dit la dernière carte n'est pas
abattu bref raymond barre hausse le ton
à lyon reportage de roland sicard et
franck bruxelles raymond barre en
famille chez lui à lyon l'ancien premier
ministre voulait aborder la dernière
ligne droite de sa campagne en terrain
de connaissance et la tortue à soc prise
fine les passes d'armes à fleurets
mouchetés tout à l'heure devant les élus
de la région rhône alpes
raymond barre à donner la raison pour
laquelle je suis je heureux d'avoir
présenté ma candidature et où je donne
raison pour laquelle je dois vous le
dire je recommencerai volontiers c'est
parce que pendant ces deux mois je me
suis efforcé de dire aux français un
certain nombre de choses
alors on ne cherchait que tous les cas
leur bander
le cas les abus et pour tout que les
petits combinaison qui se prépare plus
réussis
un discours déjà plus que musclé et
portant les choses sérieuses ne devrait
commencer que tout à l'heure dans ce
palais des sports de lyon où les
baristas tente plus de dix mille
personnes à montbard devra rappeler
cette détermination
le député de lyon croit en ses chances
et s'estime le seul à pouvoir battre
françois mitterrand au second tour
ils ont rapidement les autres temps
forts de la campagne elle affiche ce
soir philippe seguin qui montent au
créneau pour jacques chirac en première
ligne également andré lajoinie antoine
waechter et pierre boussel voici le
journal de la campagne préparer ce soir
par bernard pradines au pensez vous
qu'ils doivent y avoir un bon débat
télévisé entre françois mitterrand
jacques chirac si sur les deux premiers
au premier tour me paraît une nécessité
absolue
comment voudrais tu es ce débat selon
vous d'abord je crois qu'il devrait
ressembler parce que c'est la logique
même à celui de 1974 celui de 1980 on a
cru comprendre dans un premier temps que
monsieur mitterrand se développer devant
la perspective d'un débat dans son
principe même et puis maintenant si j'ai
bien compris il voudrait imposer débat
de style totalement dépassée du genre
des années soixante du genre de celui
qui avait opposé je crois de ceux qui l
ai dit monsieur nixon pour l'élection du
début des années 60 ça me paraît un
petit peu ringard veut dire si le
candidat du parti communiste province
dans tout le pays et bien amis camarades
c'est le fruit de votre travail de votre
diallo le vent très fort de conditions
de vent très fort tonnage pour
rassembler les gens les aider à se
défend et les idées à nos politiques
si vous voulez que l'on réponde au
chômage par la solidarité c'est à dire
par le partage du travail des revenus
si vous voulez que nous fondions notre
politique de paix sur le développement
des pays pauvres c'est à dire sur des
facteurs économiques et diplomatiques et
non sur l'accumulation d'armes
si vous voulez enfin qu'il y ait une
véritable politique qui sapent les bases
mêmes de la démogagie lepéniste c'est à
dire qu'ils fassent disparaître les
réactions de xénophobie et de racisme
alors si vous voulez donner ce sens là à
l'élection présidentielle c'est au
premier tour qu'il faut le faire
la jeunesse elle même est dans une
situation où les gens extrêmement de
fichiers c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai skié comme on l'a vu un petit
vallon contre la réforme devaquet qui
vise encore aller plus loin de réformes
savary et cheval blanc
c'est tout un ensemble qui normalement
on trouvera sa fin dans un mouvement
général des étudiants chacun sait qu
avant un mouvement des étudiants
on suppute on discute on dit que les
étudiants s'ennuie et puis brusquement
il y a ça déclenche parce que les
conditions générales à métis toujours un
déclenchement
françois mitterrand était tout à l'heure
à face au public sur france inter il a
confirmé qu'il proposerait un débat aux
candidats de la majorité qui restera en
lice pour le second tour ce soir près de
35000 personnes attendaient le candidat
mitterrand à montpellier c'est là qu'il
vient de prendre la parole il ya
quelques minutes
écoutez le
partout les menaces
partout l'oppression la guerre irak iran
y est ça a été un nouveau pas dans un
conflit
le bombardement des navires l'entrée du
détroit menacée de fermeture et
finalement la contagion à partir de
cette plaie purulente la contagion de la
guerre israël et les pays arabes
le malheur la misère est partout
époque qui se déchire un peuple à la
recherche de sa tête d'une patrie et de
l'autre celui qui a conquis le droit de
vie même
mais là c est là bas
à l'autre bout du monde l'apartheid la
ségrégation raciale
la domination des siens sur les os voilà
vous l'avez compris c'est est en ce
moment même pratiquement en direct de
montpellier dans l'hérault prolongement
de tous ses meetings dans le dernier
journal aux alentours de 23h30
aux etats unis les élections
présidentielles se profile elle aussi à
l'horizon la primaire de l'état de new
york va sans doute départager
définitivement michael dukakis et jesse
jackson les deux postulants démocrate
l'équation est simple si lucas qu'ils
gagnent il affrontera george bush qui
est sûr quant à lui d'avoir
l'investiture du parti républicain
si jackson l'emportent il risque d'y
avoir une certaine confusion dans le
rang des démocrates à new york
reportage de paul nahon et francis
friedland jesse jackson démocrate mike
dukakis démocrate deux candidats de
style radicalement différents pour une
même ville new york c'est non
washington
l'une des plus grandes métropoles du
monde 10 millions d'habitants une
mosaïque de peuples et d'ethnie c'est
eux qui feront la différence
ici les minorités sont majorité macbook
acquise d'origine grecque a besoin à new
york d'une nette victoire pour prendre
la tête
côté démocrate de la course à la maison
blanche pour l'instant il est le grand
favori dans les sondages gouverneur du
massachusetts sérieux expérimenter son
programme redonner espoir à l'amérique
lutter contre la drogue et développer la
sécurité sociale pour tous maïdo kaki ce
n'est pas un orateur et on lui reproche
son manque de charisme charisme ça vient
du grec est un manga ne vous en faites
pas j'en ai plus qu'il n'en faut moi
j'agis je ne parle pas macbook acquise
dans le quartier juif de brooklyn le
vote juif qui représente 25% de
l'électorat est capital et c'est à celui
des candidats qui se montrera le plus
proche d'israël et de la communauté
américaine my de cas qui sera la plus
grande partie de ses voix
en revanche jesse jackson pratiquement
aucune jackson essaie de donner l'image
de quelqu'un de raisonnable mais il a
des idées déraisonnable c'est peu quand
il sa vision des juifs et êtes
antisémites
il ya quatre ans en effet jesse jackson
avait parlé de new york en ces termes
c'est la ville de [ __ ] grande émotion
en amérique depuis le candidat démocrate
s'est excusé publiquement mais cette
petite phrase lui colle à la peau
tout comme ses rencontres avec yasser
arafat et fidel castro jesse jackson
mike dukakis un noir et un fils
d'émigrants sur les plus hautes marches
de la politique
tous deux ont fait bouger l'amérique les
télégrammes d'actualité avec isabelle
staes ensuite nous parlerons tennis il y
a eu quelques surprises aujourd'hui sur
le court central de monte carlo
pas de demain et vendredi sur les vols
d'air interne à air france les syndicats
de pilotes deux mécaniciens lavent leur
préavis
un geste pour faciliter la mise en place
de la médiation dans le conflit sur le
pilotage à 2 les airbus a320
les producteurs de porcs manifestants
bretagne ils protestent contre la chute
des cours les importations de porc
hollandais la confédération paysanne
dénonce l'anarchie du marché selon elle
de nombreuses exploitations sont chaque
jour en faillite
allemagne le chiite libanais abbas hamad
est condamné à 13 ans de prison
il a été reconnu coupable d'avoir
participé à l'enlèvement de deux otages
ouest allemand à beyrouth l'un d'eux ou
dolf cordesse et toujours détenus au
liban élections anticipées le 10 mai
prochain au danemark le chef du
gouvernement démissionne cette décision
fait suite à une motion adoptée au
parlement par l'opposition de gauche
celle ci interdit l'entrée des bâtiments
de guerre étrangers y compris ceux de
l'otan'' dans les eaux territoriales
danoise le thé le tennis je le disais à
l'instant triste journée pour les têtes
de série aujourd'hui dans le tournoi de
monte-carlo certes henri leconte notre
porte drapeau s'en est bien tiré mais
d'autres ont mordu la poussière dès le
premier tour c'est le cas de sanchez
tête de série numéro huit et surtout de
l'allemand boris becker tête de série
numéro 3 pourquoi et comment ils
traquaient explications de francis
maroteaux boris becker qui se fait du
souci beaucoup de soucis même et il y a
de quoi faso tchéco slovaque marian
vajda parce que cet après midi à
monte-carlo wajda de dos 23 ans 42e
joueur mondial se hisse au niveau de
l'allemand le tchèque monte au filet et
marque les plans mais le tchèque 7 aussi
attendre et tirer des passing au bon
moment et surtout au bon endroit
résultat marian vajda l'emportent en
trois sets 6-3 5-7 et 6-1 mais cet après
midi un autre favori à shooter du rocher
monégasque l'espagnol sanchez éliminé
par l'allemand meine que les autres
français jérôme potier a perdu en trois
sets face au suédois sten lounes mais
guy forget s'est qualifié aux dépens
d'un autre allemand stubbs qualifié
également tarik benhabilès quant à henri
leconte
il ne lui a fallu que deux sets pour
venir à bout de thomas schmid le tchèque
6-4 7-5
pour henri leconte vainqueur à nice la
semaine dernière c'est un peu le retour
du beau temps
et match le temps 2 0
s'ils gagnent on a vu ça marche pour lui
toujours en tennis on appris aujourd'hui
que yannick noah avait décidé de faire
l'impasse sur le tournoi de wimbledon le
numéro un français a choisi de se
reposer à partir du 6 juin le 6 juin
c'est le lendemain du tournoi de roland
garros
les courses il y avait un tiercé ce soir
sur l'hippodrome de vincennes voici les
résultats
fallait jouer dans l'ordre le dise le 2
et le 9 par les rapports bien sûr pour
l'instant mais sans doute dans le
dernier journal vers 23h30
salut l'artiste pierre desproges est
mort hier soir il avait 49 ans le porte
drapeau de l'humour du deuxième degré
parti sans prévenir
mais il laisse derrière lui des
réflexions savoureux sur la vie sur la
mort sur la politique
témoin cette évocation préparé par notre
confrère georges bigot l'émanation ne
pensez vous que 1978 sera antérieure ou
postérieure à 1977
l'intelligence et comme les parachutes
quand on en a pas on s'écrase
je pense que oui effectivement on peut
rire de tout mais pas forcément à tout
le monde
les rues de paris ne sont plus sûres
vous savez que dans certains quartiers
de la capitale les arabes n'ose plus
sortir tout seul le soir vous achetez un
seul numéro de minute pour moins de dix
balles vous avez à la fois la nausée et
les mains sales
j'ai toujours considéré que c'était le
parlement le l'artiste plus insolent que
nous ayons en france plus insolent
coluche à mon avis même si son insolence
était plus plus fine plus travailler
plus littéraire marguerite duras qui n'a
pas écrit que des conneries elle en a
aussi filmé pierre desproges n'avait pas
peur de la mort il a tourné en dérision
à ces thèmes qui revenait régulièrement
chez lui il aimait rire de la mort la
mort le faisait rire et
la sienne ne fait pas rire du tout j'ai
beaucoup écrit sur le cancer
j'ai beaucoup ri sur le cancer et j'ai
écrit ce livre au moment où quelqu'un
qui a été très cher est mort d'un cancer
ça peut paraître paradoxal mais je crois
pas je vous donne quatre ou cherchez
l'intrus connaissez le principe
métastases chimiothérapie schwarzenberg
à venir conformément à ses voeux son
attaché de presse a lu un communiqué
ainsi libellé ce matin pierre desproges
est mort d'un cancer
etonnant non c'était la dernière boutade
de desproges une sorte de pied de nez au
destin prochain journal vers 23h30 avec
aubry et de l'air juste avant nous vous
offrons une soirée cinéma sur antenne 2
soirée au cours de laquelle vous
retrouverez alain delon dans le gang un
film de jacques deray demain dès 6h45
n'oubliez pas télématin avec roger zabel
et toute l'équipe des lève tôt d'antenne
2 à 7h45 c'est philippe mestres le
directeur de campagne de raymond barre
qui sera l'invité des 4 vérités je vous
retrouve demain à 20h bonsoir dans
quelques instants la météo concocté par
sophie davant